[Música]
tengo esta idea que muy probablemente
está equivocada pero pienso que la
literatura no se encuentra estrictamente
en los libros revistas o bibliotecas las
bibliotecas esos patrones de libros
diría ulises carrión más bien pienso que
esa cosa que llamo literatura se pasea
por todos lados y entonces alto por allí
cazando situaciones o siendo víctima
constantemente de escenas narrativamente
interesantes al menos para mí mismo
aunque algunos aseguran que eso puede
llegar a ser peligroso
quien sabe entonces voy a pasar revista
por mi experiencia en cuanto a la
literatura la lectura los libros
y mis primeros acercamientos con los
libros
fue en casa en la infancia
en casa no son muy lectores en realidad
y no hay muchos libros pero había y un
mueble que no me atrevería decir librero
sino un mueble con una tele y vhs estas
figuras de patos y tenían algunos libros
y entre esos libros había una
enciclopedia de medicina y libros de
relacionados con ciencia ficción con
asuntos paranormales con fantasía con
e historias
espectaculares y verosímiles y estos
eran los libros que había en mi casa
entre ellos la biblia para niños así que
para no variar
y cuadrar con los demás después pasó y
relación de acercarme a los libros a
comenzar a leer es decir al principio no
los leía nada más lo social ya los
dibujos entonces comencé a leer y
comencé leyendo cómics cómics y
parece que tengo algo ahí de obsesión
cuento algo me gusta hallar no lo puedo
soltar y comencé a leer cómics muchos
cómics y de cómics salté a los best
sellers del momento y luego a los best
sellers de ayer y hoy
pues eso desde un stephen king hasta los
best-seller clásicos como estoy es que
yo vi que en su auto estoy para cerrar
esta temporada yo estaba estudiando
sistemas computacionales
i
pues eso de que me empezó a gustar
demasiado la lectura los libros y
decidió cambiarme de carrera a la mitad
de la carrera llevaba dos años en
sistemas computacionales y decidió
mudarme a licenciatura en filosofía
el objetivo simplemente era que me
pusieran a leer y es así como la lectura
me lleva al terreno de la escritura y
comienzo a asistir a talleres
creación literaria diplomados aquí mismo
en la laguna
tengo la fortuna de toparme por una
maestra ruth castro que al ver que
aceptaba amar papá ya sin errores me
invita a colaborar con ella es una sin
un proyecto editorial llamado a manuel
se me invita a colaborar en un proyecto
de revista fanzine que se llama palabra
palabra
comienzo a moverme en pequeños círculos
creativos acá en la sequía de la región
culturalmente y geográficamente y
comienza a relacionarme con personas que
tienen actividades literarias al final
por los libros entonces comienzo de
hojear libros a leer cómics y libros y
luego a escribir ya trabajar haciendo
libros entonces comienzo ya a discutir
me
en otro terreno de los libros
y no es eso lo que venía a contarles
centralidad sino como después de varios
años de estar trabajando y colaborando
con estos círculos relacionados por el
libro la lectura y la literatura es que
comienzan a ocurrirme
e invitaciones y colaboraciones a otros
proyectos que nada tienen que ver con la
literatura pero que sí tienen que ver
con la literatura o con la lectura o con
los libros
y quiero leerles un segundo texto y dice
así
hace algunos años viviendo en casa de
mis padres soñé con una tal pasqual a
una señora morena con el pelo lacio
lacio y con olor a eucalipto alcohol y
árnica me dijo siempre si te irás como
le dije si me dijo te espera la
monstruosa ciudad extendió una mano como
para tocar ella y se movió miras a la
monstruosa ciudad repitió y ahora me
suena orden
vas a cruzar esta puerta muchacho vas a
salir de casa y vas a arrimar tela con
gente cabrona te desesperará como no a
veces te sentirás solo y a veces querido
meter las patas verás maravillas y al
final encontraras otro hermano y aunque
estés triste llegará hasta dónde debes
llegar y una vez que estés allí
encontrarás gentes aún más chingón has
aprender es algo me lo dijo todo sin
enfatizar con elocuencia sin mover un
músculo de más en su rostro y yo me
quedé masticando todo lo dicho cierra tu
mano me dijo en ese puño llevas tu
corazón ya lo viste
no temas me dijo cruza la trans curvita
y desconfían cuando sientas demasiado
confort han pasado cinco o seis años de
este texto y saben que hace cuatro años
que vivo en una ciudad monstruosa
llamada antes
distrito federal- ahora ciudad demostró
hace cuatro años que salí de la
actualidad comarca del hidroarsenicismo
o también llamada comarca lagunera hace
cuatro años que me mudé a
a esa cosa llamada estricto federal y
comenzará a lidiar pues con todas estas
situaciones citadinas a nivel extremo
empezar a delinear por un montón de
puedes mod de chilangos un montón de
chilangos haciendo filas para todos un
montón de yilán quest yendo o viniendo
yendo en las mañanas con prisas o
regresando en las tardes con cansancio
un montón de chilangos metiendo cosas en
polillas y un montón de horarios de este
país es decir por años a la ciudad de
micro de este país y de otros países
interactuando con todos esos chilangos
no era no era que yo estuviera
trabajando en una editorial o estuviera
trabajando en una biblioteca pero a mí
me parece en situaciones muy
literal y zante es por así decirlo
narrativamente interesantes
y es eso que hay un montón de bailes los
baches tenían formas esa por ejemplo que
me topé tiene la forma de corazón del
valle y me atrevo a decir que torre o 9
es exclusiva de poseedora de los valles
parecerá que es un bien nacional efecto
incluso yo me atrevo a decirte que tengo
esta idea de que se me hace que ayuda y
después al hermético pero bueno al menos
el torreón y la ciudad de méxico sí que
los hay
formaciones
y esta ciudad maravillosa donde está la
cotidianidad
restos de piezas prehispánicas de las
topas interactuando hablado en la cubeta
con agua sucia para traficar en el metro
cosas así de 500 años y con una cubeta
que acaba de mejorar en la pieza para
que sé
descompongan y bueno estos asuntos de la
cotidianidad para mí la cotidianidad
como ir rodando si la baqueta está
desmadrada y la calle está desmadrada y
lo tienes que ir sorteando entre micros
y diablitos y triciclos
[Música]
todos esos asuntos que me parecían a mí
como
dignos de vivirlos pues en mi caso al
menos para mí
esta ciudad maravillosa de la ciudad de
méxico donde puedes comer de forma
deliciosa siempre y cuando no seas
norteño porque el norteño quiere carne
donde quiera que vaya pero cualquier
otra persona no norte ella come de
manera deliciosa en la ciudad de mexico
estas pesadillas y eso los cenotes de
paso que ella llaman les quita y le
ponen patas
y te encuentras comida de todos lados
del sur del norte de otros países
y todo eso a mí me resultaba demasiado
literario aunque no haya canon que me
dijera si sigue literario o no es
literario pero con esta idea que yo
tengo de la literatura es que yo lo lo
percibía como tal lo percibo como tal
llegan situaciones como pues eso
empezará a vivir solo empezar a cocinar
por primera vez y bueno allá me dice un
sope de salchichas para asar
eso de comenzar a comprar tus objetos de
casa de llegar y no hay nada tienes que
ir a comprar tu toalla tu sillón su
parrilla tu refrigerador
tu cucharada de alguno piensa que las
casas tienen con cucharas estos hijos
están solas y tienes que empezar
entonces tengo comenzaba a registrar
todas esas notas de la cotidianidad que
a mí me resultan
narrable contables
fui mejorando mis habilidades culinarias
y las antillas para futuros con chulitos
jugué más allá y paralelo a todas estas
experiencias es que comenzó a trabajar
como como godín entro al sector de los
godines en la ciudad de méxico y pues
esto de que existe una delegación extra
en la ciudad de mexico que no estoy acá
la delegación godínez está llena de un
montón de edificios de oficinas las
oficinas llenas de un montón de
cubículos de folders un montón de todos
pers
y para mí era importante ir a ese
terreno que los
artistas no se atreven a ir me imagino
yo que antes era prohibido ir
a los padres a las drogas a todo ese
lado oscuro y los artistas los poetas
los escritores se volcaba en esos
terrenos porque era lo prohibido yo
pienso que ahorita lo prohibido ya es
meterse a un lugar como ese a trabajar
porque son los nuevos lugares prohibidos
meterse si a lo mejor a un hospital
también sería interesante
y entonces me viento
moviendo un año trabajando en una
oficina de godín en el body nato y
comienzo a interactuar con otras
personas totalmente distintas a las que
yo estaba acostumbrado entre círculos
creativos colectivos y la cosa de la
bohemia y todo ese asunto y acá más bien
todos los trajes y corbatas infantas y
tacones con otras inquietudes y terreno
totalmente no literario no cercano a la
literatura
llegó allí por bien ser cambiadas a las
letras entonces comenzó a trabajar como
corrector de contenidos y al mismo
tiempo por lo que dije y curioso que soy
empiezo a
a meter mi cuchara de la gerencia de
inclusión laboral comienzo a formar
parte de la brigada porque la ciudad
mismo tiembla entonces me resultaba
gracioso que yo siendo un discapacitado
me haya tenido que capacitar para
y capacitar a personas sin discapacidad
sobre
los asuntos sísmicos como evacuar en un
incendio que se tiene que hacer todas
las políticas de protección civil en la
empresa
entonces comencé a dar talleres de
redacción talleres de protección civil
en cuanto a sismos y los incendios y
empezar a interactuar con un montón de
personas que no tienen que ver con la
literatura pero que a mí me resultaban
interesante contar eso vivirlo para
contarlo para compartirlo y bueno estuve
un año trabajando duramente como como
godín
así me la pasé de un año la oficina de
trabajando y
finalmente
he decidido renunciar al algo innato y
retomar mis actividades
[Música]
pues relacionadas con inquietudes ya más
creativas
y empiezo nuevamente
encontrarme
[Música]
platicaría jugaría debatir con personas
que son curiosas pero que no tienen que
ver estrictamente con la literatura es
decir con ingenieros matemáticos con
escultores
fotógrafos por estando pero con
qué más
psicoanalistas pedagogos y pero que
tienen esta inquietud por cuestionar por
sentir preguntarse por qué están
sintiendo lo que están sintiendo y
comenzó nuevamente a involucrar mejor
con colectivos con cooperativas con
sociólogos por
y creativo y
terminó hablando finalmente hace unos
cuantos meses con un colectivo que se
llama discrepantes que si no los conocen
se vienen contado estos chicos entonces
y nada más es un asunto de
un montón de manos de amigos con los que
he estado colaborando últimamente y que
se ven la diversidad del tipo de mano y
al mismo tiempo pues ellos son
sociólogos y directores de cine y eso
que no son estrictamente
el punto de la literatura pero que algo
tienen que ver con eso y para cerrar
quiero leerles un último texto muy
pequeño
que dice
en mi caso la literatura se trata más
que un simple ejercicio una herramienta
para sobrevivir ante el absurdo de la
existencia me cuesta trabajo imaginarme
sin ella no sé si la literatura sea como
unos lentes que al ponerte ves a algunas
cosas en las cosas eso que llaman la
posibilidad de las cosas oa lo mejor la
literatura simplemente anda por ahí y la
podemos pescar consciente o
inconscientemente para emocionarnos
cuestionarnos o jugar con ella no sé a
lo mejor es las dos cosas en este
sentido me identifico hasta el tuétano
con un hidalgo de hace mucho tiempo
llamado alonso quijano mejor conocido
como don quijote de la magia y por tanto
leer se le secó el polvo y comenzó a
creer en cosas que no tenían que ver con
su realidad pero que si tenían que ver
con la realidad y es así como la
literatura tenga cuidado porque mueve a
los ingenuos
desde hace tanto tiempo a otros puertos
si más allá de los libros gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]